well millions will be watching
tomorrow's super bowl here on cbs this
year there'll be far fewer fans in the
stands of course
tampa's raymond james stadium has a
capacity of around 75
000 but due to covert restrictions only
25 000
will be allowed in fortunately for three
super bowl super fans they managed to
make the cut keeping one of
sports fandom's most impressive streaks
alive
jamie yukas has their story
[Music]
as tampa bay prepares for super bowl 55
so are super fans don chrisman gregory
eaton
and tom henschel the three men have
attended every single super bowl game
since its inception
why is it so important to each of you to
make it to the super bowl
i don't know i think we're trying to
outlast one another
the three men are the only remaining
members of the never miss a super bowl
club
but their streak was put in jeopardy
this year the nfl notified us on
new year's day i get saying sorry when i
go to be able to help you
i kept calling the air phil every three
days kept bugging them
have your biggest fan you gotta help me
their pleas were answered on january
17th
with tickets to super bowl 55. are you
excited
real excited
while the nfl does help them to secure
their tickets
the payment is completely up to the fans
how much do you guys pay for tickets now
2500 2500 each
prices that seem out of bounds compared
to the 12
10 and six dollar tickets purchased for
their first super bowl game in 1967.
i don't want to point this out but none
of you are young men are any of you
nervous about coming in
during coven no no i'm a little nervous
i only have one i am i wear two glasses
the lord has blessed us all three of us
they blessed us
and i think he'll keep going less than
us in years past
the club members were able to sit
together but because of this year's
covet 19
safety measures they'll be spaced at
least eight rows apart
but will be able to enjoy their favorite
pastime together again
do you think your group is a lesson in
determination
i think you could say that yes i wrote a
letter
to goodell and for all of us
saying what saying that we hope that
they can give us tickets
because if we miss this one and went to
the next one our streak is broken
it's not good that's right you didn't
want to let kovid
kill the tradition no if they didn't
have the game that would be different
but if you're gonna have 25 000 people
there
why not have six tickets for us what
we've been through
what we've been through for 54 years
again if i had to find a nurse's outfit
and put it on i would have gotten today
i think somehow
you just heard tom say he would have put
on a nurse's outfit he said if he got
desperate enough he was going to try to
blend in
with those 7 500 vaccinated healthcare
workers
going to the game guys there's a reason
they call them fanatics
yes fanatics jamie amazing job
coordinating a zoom interview with those
great stuff thanks james